should in-laws get involved in marital
disputes I think a lot of families are
not actually equipped to deal with
disputes I think that they will be quite
judgmental and biased I I think you
could say that in some cases it's
actually Haram to get them involved in
some cases and the reality is especially
if you're even living with your in-laws
it's hard for them to ignore and you
can't really get away from it for them
to actually see it so realistically a
lot of the times you know those are the
only people that you can actually turn
to it's not really about backbiting they
actually can see your mood when you're
sitting on the table with them you if I
put a legal case on you that destroyed
your life for example I've accused you
of violence domestic violence and goes
on your record right and it's like
you're staying pretty much for Life
problem that I think we Face a lot is
especially if you come from a South
Asian background we have a very very
toxic culture which teaches us that
women should stay quiet and you know
marriage is tough It's a gamble so just
deal with it
foreign
net is raising funds to establish a
Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a Savage for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah for your donation you
and Shout Out click the link and donate
one
assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters
and dear friends hope you guys welcome
to the bitter truth show
um as you guys know we speak about
variety of topics percentage gender
roles divorce marriage Muslim people to
get married and different topics
um sometimes are controversial I just
want to give some disclaimers we are not
here uh to talk about certain matters
just for the sake of it just for some
views or just because they're
controversial but we genuinely well I'll
speak on my behalf but I also assume the
best in the people that are here today
is that we want the best you know for
our brothers and sisters who are
watching this so anyone that's
expressing something please with a
please understand that it's not coming
from place it's coming there from a
place of care so please assume the best
inshallah and yeah that's it inshallah
so today
um it's a bit different as you can see I
don't know if you can see we've got four
buzzers here my father introduced this
concept
um the shop is called bitter truth the
four buzzers are here called bitter
buzzers so the bits of others are that's
you know it's going to be maybe in terms
of bitter but the point is if you
disagree with someone and every person
in the panel has one chance to press it
once once they do the person who speak
and finishes their sentence and the
person who's pressed the device off
would have a minute and a half nobody
interrupting them to express their
counter argument or whatever it may be
inshallah so that's it so before um I'll
start I Want To Praise all the
subhanallah the most merciful the most
trust or praise His glory and breath
should belong to him and we ask Allah to
make this beneficial not only to us but
for those who are watching that form
inshallah and that it helps the family
units which are already breaking down
and is attacking their nuclear family
units as well so also we've got a very
esteemed yes
please tell us a bit about yourself
inshallah my the only special guest
sorry no no you are we always have the
special guest everyone's a special guest
but you because you've come from far you
are the special special guest yeah vvip
yeah in China so please tell us a bit
about yourself and then we'll go to our
very special guest uh our brother who's
very close to my heart as well so yeah
tell us about yourself what did you do
um
my name
Islamic psychology counselor I've been
Muslim for about 20 years now
alhamdulillah and most I focus on
counseling mental health relationships
and so on masculinity yeah yes yeah
yeah
usually it's customary for the house to
you know introduce the guests yes I need
to learn that inshallah so the esteemed
guests the great wonderful that's also
known as the Learned one yeah
I wanted to have you guys here and our
Dear honorable sisters may Allah bless
them for being here uh they'll play a
very important role in this discussion
inshallah starting from
um if you can just introduce yourself um
I'm Vince Athens
um a mother of two and um currently
working as a nursery teacher
[Music]
and a mother of one currently divorced I
work in school
I'm fahima Mohammed and I'm a
broadcaster also a life coach NLP
practitioner CBT uh therapist also
currently studying my masters in the
final stage of neuroscience and
psychology of mental health and I do
help people in the community in
different backgrounds male and female
with regards to all kinds of issues and
especially relationships and appear on
several different TV channels including
um mainstream and different sects and
different backgrounds as well so try to
represent within the community and
outside the community talking about
social issues and relationship issues as
well
I'm going to introduce a topic here at
home today uh but just so you guys are
aware this is what the buzzer sounds
like
so if you hear it please finish your
sentence and the person is press it give
them the chance to speak with her so the
topic today
is the following
um should in-laws get involved in
marital disputes
so that's just a
put it out there
um we can talk about what kind of
disciplines we're talking about later
minor major but in general
um let me start with another Gabriel do
you believe that in-laws should get
involved in every marital dispute
non-marital disputes what's your take on
it
so it depends I guess what the issues
are
because Allah tells us in the Quran
about where and at what position do you
choose an arbitrator from her family and
from his family right it's usually I
kind of like the late stage before
you're about to separate right
and what happens today what we see is
that it's the first thing that people do
right as soon as there's an issue
um that is what's happening everyone
gets involved and instead of solving
problems because obviously there's
emotional attachments to each side
biases people are going to make mistakes
if I'm a father if my daughter gets
married to someone most likely I'm not
well versed I'm not
uh wise yeah and I don't understand the
Sharia and the procedures I'm probably
gonna I'm probably gonna side with my
daughter isn't it true it shouldn't be
like that but if you were human beings
right and it's it's a hard thing to do
but the bitter truth is that we
shouldn't usually yeah
um sisters what's your take on it like
do you think that in-laws should be
involved from the very get-go later
stage minor argument major argument
where would you get your family or his
family involved in a dispute
okay well my opinion again also differs
because it depends on um the actual
dispute and I think a lot of families
are not actually equipped to deal with
dispute I think that they will be quite
judgmental and biased and also there's
an effect of it coming back on them even
if the couple has resolved their issues
so that they will keep it in them and
even if the couple wants to move forward
it will always be a reminder and
unfortunately with human mind and
behavior unless they are trained to be
able to control themselves and not feel
the need to interfere and remind them
um they can actually push back the
actual couple
um to resolve the issues and I think
again like the brother mentioned I think
a lot of people are very judgmental and
they're very protective as well you can
understand that so I think it's best to
even if they can't resolve it between
themselves to seek an outside
perspective a professional or a Wally or
whatever it is that they started off
with
okay
um I personally think that it depends on
your in-laws so oh sorry so I think it
depends on your in-laws like you know
your in-laws best um and it also depends
on the situation you're in I would say
don't get them involved unless it's
something like serious and I think you
can judge that so I can't speak on
everyone but I would say look at your
in-laws how much knowledge do they have
how do how well do they know you both
are they Fair people and if so then do
get them involved but if you can resolve
it between you then obviously don't get
them involved
yeah adding on to by what the sister
said it depends on the kind of
relationships you have with them so we
have three sides here we've got his side
her side and then the truth and the
point is for all of us to work together
to get to the truth not be biased not
fight against each other as long as we
can agree that we're all on that same
page and that we have the best interests
for one another then I think you should
but that's more at a later stage
definitely not in the early days
but
the sister side or the problem I said
this is my truth so he dropped I don't
know like you know we speak to a lot of
people a lot of people comments for
advice
um what's your take on like him knows
getting involved
um do you think they should get involved
straight away at all what should take on
it I think I was speaking from an
Islamic Paradigm that we have to kind of
compartmentalize the situation and you
can probably say that what you can
rephrase the question what is the hukum
what is the ruling of again involved
okay and I I think you could say that in
some cases it's actually Haram to get
them involved in some cases it's Helen
some cases must have happened and I
think that for for you to have a
successful Islamic marriage you need to
know which is which for example in the
Haram case is many men or women will
speak with their parents about their
apartment this is
yes of course if for example a woman is
complaining to her mum or her husband or
a man is complaining to his mother about
her his wife because he's trying to
placate them for example now this
there's the general ruling is that
you're not allowed to speak about
someone behind their back for example
right so you're saying I want to get my
family involved but what you're actually
doing is you're biting you're backbiting
your brother or your sister in Islam and
you're getting a major sin so that
that's a clear indication that or an
example of when getting your family
involved can be Haram
uh a situation whereas for example
um
allowed would be if there's Mutual
consent between both parties and you say
Okay I want to get this person involved
the way the Quran phrases is
you know if you face separation between
them then get someone from his family
someone from her family if you look at
if you pay attention to that verse it's
not speaking to the marriage uh to the
husband and wife
speaking to some other members of the
community because in the third person
not in the second so the question is
who's it speaking to foreign
[Music]
between them
and then you know he was suggesting
names and then she would say no and yes
and so on
anyway she brought her father in and it
was not a good idea for her because I
mean the story is well known I'm not
gonna go into it now maybe some people
don't know well so they were suggesting
names and then she brought her father in
and our father was very uh she was
taking the process to a very high degree
so he she thought maybe that the bias
would be in her Direction but it was
certainly not it was the opposite that's
interesting because it goes back to a
cable said because sometimes it's
Father's righteous mothers it's because
it's our blood and we talk about the
Iman is bigger than blood uh
actually it's open yeah it's it's quite
beautiful yeah exactly so I mean the
point I'm making with this is that it's
the confuses to happen the arbitrator so
in this case we don't have a ruler or a
judge but let's say for example you have
an arbitrator yes the arbitrator says
bring someone from his family bring
someone back and there was an Arabic
which really comes with the connotation
as a Hakeem a wise person you can't just
bring anybody and it's not just
necessarily the father and mother it's
the quranic method on this issue is not
bring the in-laws involved you just
bring the person who you think in that
family family is most qualified might
not be the father Mark could be the
grandfather it could be the uncle maybe
it could be anybody right whoever you
feel is the the continuation of the
verses
that if they want to
if they want to uh reconciliation then
Allah will make them successful you know
so which means that he also these two
people have to want to reconcile one
another so I don't think that the issue
of getting the in-laws involved nowadays
a lot of divorces actually are
predicated on that yes so the woman goes
to her father and she starts mentioning
certain things to him about the husband
and that's it it's a write-offs now
after that it's on it's irrevocable
damage and so these kind of things need
to be kind of weighed up and thought
about and you Gabriel and other people
that do counseling probably know more
than me I've haven't done counseling
like that so a lot of divorces I'm
guessing are because of the in-laws
involvement and I feel that therefore
the basic policy should be not to get
them involved unless it's a health and
safety issue at all well I mean unless
it's a health and safety issue or unless
there's an arbitration there's consent
and there is you know there's a whole
deliberation process interesting like in
today's time when you're talking about
for example help um
situations or maybe not to that extent
but you know what you mean but in
today's time though it's um
I want to be careful I don't want to
save people up it's no flex here because
these things will happen but any little
mining things like do you see this you
do canceling you do counseling from
mistaken yeah do you guys see people
coming over like like and then they want
their parents involved have you seen the
detrim because I have my own I want you
guys to um I guess as Muhammad said it
depends on what does it mean to get
someone involved right so in most cases
the wife will go to them her mother her
father and start complaining about the
husband
or even going to a guy's Mom right she
has a good relationship with her star
which obviously is going to uh
feedback by actually not getting them
involved as a as a hacking but you're
just basically going behind and
complaining and obviously these people
are not going to get the full picture
one
rule of thumb constant means that you
can never ever just take one side or
just listen to one all right
he doesn't come in here one side because
we do this a lot like I realize it's
impossible yeah it's like I'll speak
about this and would you know he would
say he had to like train himself and to
do this in the context source that you
will have a sister coming and she's
crying like I'll be honest like I've had
a situation like that similar and I'm
just like oh my gosh this this who is
this like who's this guy and then and
then goes then you go and speak to the
husband and vice versa vice versa
sometimes the husband comes and he makes
our team like the wife is this and you
speak and you're like no you didn't tell
me about this and you didn't tell me
about that and you were saying this one
there was context behind it I would say
about 80 of the cases the story can
change anywhere from
90 degrees to 180 home still not I mean
the other way it's when you listen to
the other side as well and then you'll
ask like what why don't you say this oh
I was upset well I was uh you know this
or oh
like no no but you don't understand what
you've caused now
but I was angry
on and in the moment you know you're
talking about not just
someone's upset family is angry you're
talking about here police cases uh legal
issues right custody of children
so when Allah tells us about this
procedure
right A lot of people they want to
follow
the procedures of the Quran Sunnah when
it suits them but it doesn't suit them
right then they'll follow other
procedures and in the end this
detrimental people don't realize it till
it actually happens when it happens it's
very hard to go back and fix things if
you if I put a legal case on you that
destroyed your life for example I've
accused you of I heard today I'm
speaking to a case yeah I've accused you
of violence domestic violence it goes on
your record right and it's like you're
staying pretty much for life like for
example in Canada you can't get a job
anymore wow right the guys like this had
a masters who spent his whole life in
I.T senior rep and all of a sudden now
you can't get a job in a school bro
that's that's what you're talking about
and there's actually next month we've
got
um a couple two brothers coming who went
through a divorce and they were the the
the the the the sister stopped them from
seeing the kids and not only that that
one of them actually had a hidden camera
where she testifies to falsely
um choosing him off rape and she
actually says it on camera that yeah I
was just um
it wasn't true yeah these are fathers
actually battling to see their kids as
well yeah this is we need to raise a
winner so this is the next one inshallah
but sister FEMA you you coach
um and the main Artist as well I don't
know if you guys have heard experiences
what are your thoughts you know do you
do coaching do you see this phenomena
when would you say do you agree with the
prophets about you know maybe getting
um them involved later on and hijab did
mention that in some instances it can be
Haram
um maybe we can maybe just understand a
bit better because if the system is
going genuinely under the the husband
has said something which is true uh but
we'll come to that we'll come to that
just to understand but what's your take
on the experience that you've had I mean
it's great to have all of that sort of
you know said in a particular way but a
lot of us don't understand our Dean and
the reality is especially if you're even
living with your in-laws it's hard for
them to ignore and you can't really get
away from it for them to actually see it
so realistically a lot of the times you
know those are the only people that you
can actually turn to it's not really
about backbiting they actually can see
your mood when you're sitting on the
table with them and that's how it works
so we've got to be realistic about this
kind of things and at the same time
maybe your parents are the only ones or
the in-laws that you can turn to in
those extreme circumstances because I've
had loads of cases of abuse where they
had to flee from the house and they had
to have the people involved in the house
in order to do that so as much as we say
what we say and we have all the rulings
reality unfortunately does not show that
and there is no leader or arbitrary or
whatever you want to call it that's
actually there to stand up for all
Muslim men and women and especially
women and the men's side is always
taking first even in divorce so we need
to also raise awareness
taking the horse man's side most of the
time
well most of the chefs um they find it
very difficult go into that yeah yeah
okay so you press the pizza button yeah
so so sorry
but one one and a half minutes to
express but you said something you said
can you repeat that again please so we
can a lot of
um
the Shacks or imams are not necessarily
on the side of the women especially when
it comes to divorce or any dispute
between husband and wife okay you have
one and a half minutes so Allah means
well like how many did you quanticize
that like well I've been coaching for
seven years and I would say 90 of it I
would say that a lot of Demands
especially in the last 10 years
um in America Canada because of of the
rise of feminism and the change in the
Dynamics cultural Dynamics I say guys
now are very very afraid to rule on
behalf of the men it's most likely
they're leaning towards women
um and not just only in Muslim
counseling but non-muslim counseling
usually now people are leaning mostly
towards the wind because of a lot of the
accusations and things that happen I
mean men have kind of been stained in
the past I would say two decades and a
lot of guys are very very careful now to
not rule it's almost like a an
affirmative action or you know kind of
overcompensating on the other side
that's what I've seen why in the UK is a
little bit different exactly in the UK
there's a there's a problem
there is a problem for that yeah I
understand that what how does that
release
councils are not that many I know what
you're talking about in the U.S but in
the UK we're kind of on the other side
of the extreme I've seen the US stuff
that's that's one solid issue a lot of
my clients are from the University I
would say 70 of you know it's difficult
to hold after a woman in the UK very
difficult but on what basis is being
asked because you need to understand I
get there but it's like for example I'm
comparative is the Muslim countries yeah
like for example if uh if a woman wants
to get a collar in Egypt or Morocco it's
much easier for us to do that yeah but
is there is there a reason why the
squanders are refraining from giving the
hola Supply yes um there's not enough
councils in the in London's other
popular is one million people for
example and when the hola cases happen
they there's only like two or three
major councils so they don't know where
to go and there's a bit of a problem
with authority as well okay so where to
go is different to not being given so in
that I think we understand things like
you know the the Sharia Council the main
launcher hasn't had that yes
the average waiting time for woman to
get a whole lot is a very long time like
more than what would be usually the case
and that's because that's because of the
supply and demand issue not not that
because what's in the famous saying that
there's a favoritism going on that
that's what she says no but there is
there is an argument as well no and we
have to look at that we have to look at
that because a lot of these uh sure
councils we have to look at things Case
by case for example the the the one in
um in London I've also in his favorite
system but there's a lot of complaints
yeah there's a lot of complaints and we
kind of have to look at that well the
imams are sorry to interrupt you but the
imams Unfortunately they may know the
dean but they don't know the counseling
and human mind and behavior as well so
they also need to be understanding of
how to actually
um coach or understand you know the two
people or get someone with them because
even though they have other
um because I have a lot of shirts and
imams you know recommend me to help them
throughout their sessions or afterwards
with their people right we've gone
through it but they don't don't have a
system set up and the authority as well
it's very much here and there which
Community you belong to if you know them
very well they're not going to go and
actually you know give that divorce to
that particular family because they're
close to that share for Newman so these
things do actually help it okay true the
topic kind of dive into it so we are
talking about divorce but let's get back
to marital disputes and in-laws getting
involved um you just seems to be a
little bit quiet maybe so then if you
want to see if there's nothing it's fine
but um getting in-laws involved
um at what stage Do You Believe or at
any stage
um for me personally like if I have like
a marriage dispute like that's severe
they have like in my husband's culture
they go to the elders so by the elders I
don't mean you're direct indoors but the
oldest person in that Community because
they tend to be wiser and they tend to
have dealt with cases or dealt with a
situations like that before and everyone
respects the older so can't even get
with the older and they will discuss you
know how to resolve this and I think
that's a really good method
I feel like the only reason that a woman
would go to someone else is because she
does she just wants to release or she
wants to kind of resolve it I don't
think she would just go for the sake of
backbiting or for the sake of you know
trying to cause more problems I think
it'll be a genuine need for her to go to
talk to someone to kind of resolve it or
maybe there's something that her
husband's doing and she doesn't want to
expose him and the you know the other
option would be to go to someone that
already knows him so I think it's fine
but there's a there's a only if there's
a need not just for the sake of talking
or backbiting or and I don't think it's
a good idea to go to the mothers on
either side
yeah so I guess it comes down to
intention as well because if you're
going to your parents so you can back by
or in other words release it but not
necessarily fix it or change your ways
because remember we're both at fault
here it's not just him it's not just you
need to have that trust in that Elder
whether it's your mother-in-law or even
far relative it doesn't have to be your
direct in-laws it could be anybody
that's older than you who has the same
intention which is to make your marriage
work
the problem that I think we Face a lot
is especially if you come from a South
Asian background we have a very very
toxic culture which teaches us that
women should stay quiet and you know
marriage is tough It's a gamble so just
deal with it and that's really not the
case because now that we've figured out
that as women we have a voice and we
don't have to stay in abusive
relationship when we do go to these
Elders they're not from our generation
nor would they understand it so their
advice is what they would have done in
their time so we have to make sure that
when we are listening to the elders or
whoever may be we have to extract what
is beneficial for us today and what is
relatable for us and that's going to
help us today in to fix our marriage and
not what worked for them back in the
days if you want your marriage to work
you'll try all means it won't just be oh
yeah I went to my mother-in-law yes I
went to my audience my dad said no
that's it at the end you will go to
marriage counseling you will do therapy
if you have to do a lot of these
problems arise because of the trauma
within ourselves it's not necessarily
because he's our fault and it's just him
it's how we behave and our reaction to
maybe something that he may have done
and we have to understand that okay
yes just chime in and over because I
didn't address the first part of what
you said before which was about like you
know the reality on the ground and you
were talking about like your parents
have maybe the only people they can turn
to Etc
uh and then you talk about abuse and all
this kind of things I think it's really
important to unpack all the stuff like
in the first instance is when you said
that well you know it could be back
buying but then at the same time like
you know your parents are the only
people that you can turn to uh
you know there are soul principles which
are basically the principles of
jurisprudence for life for example I did
mention in the initial articulation that
one of the exceptions would be health
and safety issues okay so if we put that
to the side for a second and consider
that or the ruling because if we start
speaking in a sense in a way which
can undermine the rulings of Islam then
it can be problematic in the sense that
would say well in reality these rulings
are not actually pragmatic enough for us
so if we speak like that then in a sense
it can be problematic and say okay well
I have the golden ticket that I can do
ever I want because I've got trauma then
it becomes a self-flagrating Endeavor no
one can hold in anyone else to account
um let alone themselves to account so
there has to be a level of
self-reflection self-accountability
um especially vis-a-vis the Islamic
ruling so with for example the ruling of
backbiting
the hustle of it is Haram this is very
clear like you know and the person told
us what what is he says that is
that you mentioned about your brother
and obviously your sister as well that
which you that which they would hate for
that which they would dislike so for
example now going back to the issue of a
man going to his mum or a woman going to
a mum for example and speaking about an
intimate detail the stuff that's going
on in the house now there's not enough
evidence in Islam to say that well
actually she can do that because quote
unquote she's the only person that can
turn to you can say well actually is
there harm yes but there's harm there's
you know things which cause harm can
make something Halal or Haram Halal and
stuff like that
but if there's no actual physical harm
going and speaking about your partner
you know to your parents and stuff like
this and with the excuse of okay I'm
going to try and heal much rumors or
whatever it may be quote unquote okay
yeah because I that's why I said because
a lot of them or generally all of us
don't know our Dean in order to be able
to do what you just said
so that's the problem no but it's true
that's the reason and so they just think
like you mentioned it as such a big word
backbiting they wouldn't even look at it
as backbiting talking about their own
husband just expressing what's going on
in the household that's the difference
interject um I think I just want to
connect a few points we spoke about hola
yes then you spoke about the imams not
being qualified I do talk about this in
in some of my lectures problem is when
we're dealing with such a deep issue
is that the frame that we're working
within is not an Islamic one we don't
live
in a place where you can actually go to
a party and a judge right so a lot of
times our problems that we're discussing
here you have this show being pragmatic
and applicable versus theoretical and as
you said you cannot say well you know
it's not really working therefore let's
put aside to show yeah like it's not
like we need to look at which frame
we're working with yes a lot of our
problems when it comes to marriage
divorce women being aware a lot of times
women being divorce they'll say we get
thrown to the curb in Islamic State the
Amir is responsible for that because
they'll say well we don't have anyone I
don't have a father I don't have a one
I'm a new Muslim yes boom right by the
way right we get thrown to the curb like
no it doesn't really work like and then
what do you say like slams fall how many
rivers sisters leave Islam because they
get divorced and they see a bad example
of some right in Islamic frame you
wouldn't write the Emir right away yeah
to provide the you know the the
would basically be uh taking care of her
and all that so it's not as simple right
we're talking here about living America
UK US Canada whatever
a lot of these problems are because of
the frame that were Within
um I think
obviously it's not part of our
discussion but just to remind
our brothers and our sisters that you
can't fix one
wrong with another you know you can't
say what Islamic rules are not really
applicable right now the the demands and
the the uh you know odar are not really
qualified to understand the realities of
what's Happening we can we need to fix
this so counselors with imams training
we need to work on that to be able to
fix it from you know if it's fixed
problem but like that just come to me
yeah I'm the one who's qualified or you
know I know exactly because I've been
through it a lot of the problems with
counselors and
I don't know I mean in my experience
it's a bit of Truth state in my
experience with sister counselors is
that who have been divorced and they go
into counseling coaching because they've
experienced and they want to help right
I always say to sisters don't go to a
divorce system for advice because it
shows
sorry yeah
don't go to a divorced sister for advice
okay just because she's been go through
her sister who has was able to overcome
the problem and successfully continue
her marriage okay then you get advice
about divorce about marriage someone who
has was succeeded or succeeded in that
in that era um sister FEMA you have
um you have one and a half minutes
starting now well firstly
um I think when you are trained
regardless of anything
um even if you're not divorced you won't
be able to give the right sort of advice
and firstly counselors and coaches do
not give advice they give guidance and
they use techno you know
psychological strategies and tools that
open up so that every case is for that
particular person and I really don't
believe that anyone should be giving any
advice to anyone uh based on their own
personal experience because if you are
in a professional way that would never
happen anyway so you just got to make
sure that they are trained and I've come
across many couples who have gone
through exactly what I've gone through
even in my own divorce but I've actually
taken sort of much more insight into the
opposing sort of a partner like the male
which you wouldn't expect from someone
like me if you knew my background story
only because I'm professional and I'm
trained even though I'm divorced and I'm
single and at the same time if you
really have that mindset of
understanding your professional way then
don't make these sort of statements
about don't go to somebody who's
divorced and I don't believe you should
go to somebody who's divorced who hasn't
healed but definitely go to a
professional who is trained accredited
and don't judge them for who they are
because again don't even get judged on
that particular way for being divorced
and you know they are not actually
healed or they can't give the right
advice
yeah that's I respect your opinion I was
given my opinion what I've experienced
what I've seen from my Counseling of
course two different counselors can have
different experiences as well
um
obviously no counselors Madison you know
infallible that's something we have to
keep in mind just because you're trained
does not mean that you're going to be
100 professional so it's a fallacy to
believe that just because I have the
qualifications I'm not going to make
mistakes so obviously you're going to
look at the track record of that person
what's come out of that how many you
know cases the reviews and all that
right that's what we go based on okay um
in my experience a lot of the sisters
who have gone through female counselors
they will come to a male counselor and
this is by Allah I'm quoting what they
say what's the reason I'm just curious
yeah I would say is basically uh females
are going to project their own issues
onto our issues and would rather hear
from a man or take a man's uh approach
onto this issue again let's go based on
what I say and I'm by Allah I'm saying
that this is my experience we trust you
and it's not one case it's not a stiff
now or exception we're talking about uh
you know yeah
is that no no what you say yeah yeah the
thing the thing is yes it's important
because I'll be honest with you like one
of the reasons one of the reasons I
stopped the show is because I genuinely
sometimes I want to understand a female
mind but I want to understand it and I
understand exactly that's why I believe
where you're coming from they would
maybe go into a female Council they will
cover maybe a male counselor would say
you know let me speak to a female cancer
maybe understand them better
just I know I'm the host here but I have
you know sometimes I'll talk too much on
the Shelf back but one thing I want to
give you based on experience I've seen
people and I would I I genuinely believe
this would maybe benefit inshallah
people yeah is like for example
I'm just in top of Mind should I give a
okay I'm just I'm just going to say it
and say to Allah okay we are we are
married yes we are married Yeah well
yeah yeah okay so sometimes we have
arguments arguments and no one's about
marriage
sometimes if I get into marital this
people with my wife yeah
my mom would come and say to me for
example what happened what happened what
happened Allah is my witness yeah and my
wife is here she's here yeah she knows
and while I tell my mom I call Mom
give me my wife don't worry why as soon
brother
let me tell you why okay you know why
yeah because my mom will come and say
you know what kind of last time are you
I'm your mother you should open up to me
and I've got mum you know what I don't
actually yeah you know what I don't
because the thing is here argumentative
let's suppose argument saying my wife
did something to upset me me telling my
mom that do you think my mom's going to
be like oh our relation is going to
improve more well why and I say that me
and my like my wife and I tell this to
many people as well that have this
principle never ever unless it's like oh
I don't know um I took a gun out towards
my wife or you know there was a sword
involved or something like this yeah he
doesn't understand the work you said
about life and death here but make it a
principle do not let your arguments
whatever it may be wife can get upset
the husband get upset make it to
principle no we are not going to tell
you why because you're self-sabotaging
because the moment you say that argument
said if my wife goes and says Ali said
this and he upset me do you think her
mom's going to be like my mother going
to be that oh I I increased in love
towards my son-in-law more no it's going
to fight him he came up to upset if I go
to my mom and I say to my mom you know
my wife did this and stuff why did she
do that
the problem is you're self-sabotaging
now and you're ruining that relationship
but that's one perspective that's just
one perspective but I believe genuinely
the moment the in-laws start getting
like towards a Doctrine or to the sun in
law from there it's it's it's it's it's
one one maybe just a theoretical Point
um since I've been in the fields of
counseling as you guys have many of you
have which is that it just makes sense
on a theoretical level just to think
that or if you love someone more which
romantic love is a very powerful thing
now the husband and wife love each other
quite a lot or they have love for each
other yeah uh now if there's a Fallout
they're more likely this is just me
thinking to forgive each other
afterwards why because love is a great
incentive to forgive well that level of
romantic love that a partner has for the
other partner the husband for the wife
and vice versa
is unlikely to be had by the in-laws yes
so when the when the when the Fallout
happens now yes you might have forgiven
your wife or you might have forgiven
your husband but we don't know if your
in-laws are forgiven that that is the
point here and that's why my country
they say that when the wife and her
husband argues don't get involved
because you know what they're going to
both turn on you
anymore
no my dad doesn't get involved why not
at all like when I'm in like position to
be honest like I don't really like when
it comes back I don't go to my dad you
know women or dad my wife no I don't
really do that yeah but like when it
comes to my my mom my mom like for
something like okay oh you look a bit
upset today what happened it's nothing
and I'm like Mom don't worry it's not
that deep because to me it's my wife I
can forgive and move on but if I tell
her like I said before it's just going
to be like oh I should do that for and
decide the same words of vice versa so
personally I would say unless it's
something really where you are like you
know what I've decided I'm gonna end it
or whatever it may be yeah and we're not
obviously assistance can be more
emotional yeah that's you know if
there's any famous watching this and
that's a reality yeah yes the left side
of the brain and the right side of brain
it operates differently between men and
women
yes exactly so that's uh that's the
Neuroscience behind it yeah so the point
is and sometimes sisters tend to
initiate divorce more 70 to 80 actually
it's very interesting if if she's
earning more than her husband it goes to
80 percent
so from that angle you know the wife
might say something but anyways but I
think for the genders it might differ
slightly because when I was married if I
was to go to my mum she'd still take my
husband's side effects
she wanted to make it work and she's
like you calm yourself down for Hima
this whatever may Allah may Allah
it depends on the parents yes exactly
exactly that's a little bit quieter I
don't know what should take on the whole
matter
um like do you agree do you disagree you
know my statement hijabs
what's your take on it you know um you
said my dear sister what's your name I
forgot I will just I you said that um
you mentioned it um that he was you got
divorced
um obviously I don't want to get
personal about his own experience maybe
it could be by your friends getting
in-laws involved it's a detrimental
would you would you not you can make it
General it doesn't anything specific to
yourself
um again what I say is just based on my
case and in my case it was detrimental
and I think it was actually one of the
reasons why our divorce did happen but
at the same time I think I just want
everyone to remember that just because
they're your elders and they have more
knowledge it doesn't mean that they are
necessarily right and it doesn't mean
that you have to believe and act upon 99
of their words you we've got so much
knowledge alhamdulillah everywhere
around us we've got marriage counselors
we've got therapy as we've got
so many therapies you have to find your
way through this and you have to extract
what's beneficial for you so your Elder
might say look forgive him and maybe you
just needed that nudge to forgive him
maybe if you had resulted to look in
Google or social media a lot of us now
travel too it would have made you hate
him even more and it's such a petty
thing like Ali said if it's something
small
try to forgive him and go down that
route rather than calling up your mum or
your dad and getting their opinion of it
you have to learn what works for you
but but subtracting everything but like
getting your information from all
sources not just one thing because even
though you might go to a marriage
counselor they're not going to have all
the answers for you because your case is
unique to you and your opinion your
childhood your upbringing your family
so learn to extract what works for me
from all the resources around you before
you give up on that marriage
I can just
oh this is interesting this whole Elder
framework I'm not really privy to it
I'll be honest like I'm just going to
the elders and stuff like that it's not
really something we may be doing our
culture as much uh as a subcontinent but
what I'll say is there's a few things I
was reading
um Jordan Peterson's book actually of
all books which one and the newest one
the 12 more rules and in the end of that
book he was speaking in detail about
negotiating with your partner and stuff
like that and so what I find interesting
is that he's he was like you know he was
saying that you need to be able to
negotiate and flesh these things out
blah blah blah blah blah and then you
start talking about tradition now the
issue of tradition is people have found
ways to make things work for thousands
of years now that's what tradition
really is people have found think ways
to make things work for thousands of
years we and we have a scholarly
tradition we have I don't know what the
subcontinent tradition looks like the
elders they kind of know how to resolve
issues
now the issue is when people try and
reinvent the wheel the age of social
media if you get someone trying to
reinvent the wheel so now I want to know
how to make this work and let's go to a
counselor let's go to a psychotherapist
let's go let's take an antidepressant
and it's this cocktail of trial and
error in many ways it can be inefficient
I'm not saying it is necessarily
inefficient that's one point away it can
be so you have to kind of yes on the one
hand there's there is a limitation a
clear limitation with the Elder
framework whatever that may be but
there's also a very major limitation
with the new modern framework as well
the social media framework the answers
what do they do then why I think people
need to realize is that everyone has an
agenda and everything has assumptions
okay so for example when someone's doing
um counseling and if they're doing if
they're doing psychology counseling for
instance Freudian psychology type
counseling or talking therapy or these
kind of things there is an assumption
here and quite frankly I think some of
it is problematic from Islamic
perspective and once again I'm just
speaking theoretical but for instance
the psychologist framework one of the
things that they assume
there's kind of like a moral ambiguity
you don't they don't tell you what's
right and wrong in fact it's
inappropriate for them to tell you
what's right and wrong yeah I think this
um you know for example this was yeah if
you look at in famous uh in in culture
those is The Sopranos right and so this
idea of The Woman
the series
there's a man going to like a woman and
she was uh you know giving him advice
and so on and at one point and this I
watched it some time ago
um like 90s or something I don't know
when it came out but there was one
particular episode it was very
interesting and I still remember
where they were criticizing the
councilor system by saying this is like
a moral relativism you can't tell I mean
one guy was speaking to the counselor
the woman that was speaking to Tony the
the mafia leader and he was saying you
can't even tell him that what you're
doing is morally wrong
you see what the point is so when you go
to a counselor you're not going to
expect the council to tell you look what
you're doing is Haram what you're doing
is hard exactly that's one very
important thing now another another
thing I've add to that is
so moral guidance and psycho Spiritual
Development are inextricably linked what
counseling does is actually separates us
which is it's a very dangerous thing
from my perspective because it can lead
to more relativism another thing I'll
add to that is
um actually it can be detrimental in so
much as it can make you blame your
parents especially Counseling in the UK
I know in any kind of cycle analysis if
you've studied it on a theoretical level
you'll know that psychoanalysis quite
frankly it traces everything back to
your upbringing
so we've heard the the the the bus term
daddy issues for example yeah this daddy
issues thing is overplayed why is it
overplayed because it's based on
psychologic assumptions a woman has some
uh traumatic event oh it's probably
because she has some daddy issues
no no the reason why they're saying that
is because the Assumption of Freudian
psychologist Frameworks is that most of
your traumas can be traced back to
something that's happening in your early
life
now what which can be true which can be
true I'm not saying it's pretty false
it's not it's not something you can say
it is true that's an assumption it's not
something everything's an assumption
when it comes to science no it's not
psychology
the difference between the difference
between something which is verifiable
from the scientific method and it's an
assumption of it it's an assumption of
something which is used to prove a point
rather than something which is improved
from the scientific method so I mean
sorry to say but it's you saying it's
true it's it's kind of the theoretical
underpinnings of psychoanalysis might be
under uh kind of ambiguous to yourself
in the sense that for example Carl Poppa
famous died in 1994 he propounded
falsification
well one of the things which are now
Cornerstone of the scientific method you
refer to the whole Venture of psychology
as a pseudoscience it doesn't even meet
the threshold of Natural Sciences so
psychoanalysis is just one school of
thought within the psychology and so to
say something is fully true it's not
plausible from the scientific absolutely
it's only from certain amounts of
research and it might apply to a certain
group of people absolutely correct let
me just finish the point because there's
a bit more I wanted to add to this which
is that when you do the Psychotherapy
like talking certain these kind of
things here a lot of people come out of
it hating their parents why because it
was your dad's fault that happened it
was your mum's fault that that happened
it was goes back to this kind of thing
from an Islamic perspective this penting
up of resentment to your parents is more
dangerous sometimes than it is
beneficial because for us one of the the
Apex moralities is that you're meant to
be good to both of your parents so if
you go to a counselor and they say well
what happened when you were eight years
old nine years old oh your mom does that
okay so then you start to shift blames
you like true not taking accountability
yeah yeah and they sound that we live
you know so so in summary therefore say
that cycle analysis for talking therapy
is just one methodology of psychology
there's many others there's behavioral
psychology the the CBT method that they
use also in the NHS the cognitive
behavioral therapy method all of them
have different assumptions now I'm not
saying there's no truth in any of them
I'm just saying we have to be skeptical
of all of them exactly that's what I'm
saying except the Quran
I think one very
um observable
phenomenon that we can see is we have a
lot of psychologists psychiatrists
counselors coaches you name they've
increased a lot wouldn't you agree over
the last decade or so
um however divorce has also increased
right but not all of them go to them
because it's so healing I do believe
that the Muslim Community they hardly
seek most of these things
about the Muslims we have to understand
there's going to be a very close there's
a correlation between the non-muslims
and Muslims the Muslims indeed we follow
within a few years behind and most of
the things said you will follow him
would need some not that additional I
think this is beyond the scope of this
part yeah we can do that no doubt but
just on an observable uh you know term
we see that there's been a lot of Muslim
counselors let's say within the Muslim
Community okay a lot of Muslim coaches
counselors and so on and people do go I
mean people are busy I'm sure you're
busy oh and the ones that I know it for
yet still
um
a lot of problems are still taking place
a lot of
issues are still taking place why are we
not solving these problems my argument
would be this and I agree with you is
that looking at most of the counselors
they have gone through CBD training
they've gone through secular training
they've done their Master's phds how
many of them have Islamic qualifications
yeah that'll be my argument I would like
to see sure yeah for sure that's true
the ones that I know it's not you know
they will put
they will filter the Islamic Paradigm
through a secular Paradigm as opposed to
the other way around it's true
detrimental you're going there to help
it's going to end your marriage further
but I think the other point is a lot of
people go seeking counseling and marital
um sort of like coaches is because it's
right at the end of that relationship
anyway so that's the other reason why it
does fail because they actually already
resenting each other and they think this
is my last resort and I always advise
them as soon as you feel that you just
tolerate a new relationship and it's not
that great that's when you see them and
that's where some of these therapies and
things can work and there's a lot of
fraud around it and fake you know
coaches and counselors or whatever they
may be as well you know not particular
you know aligned with Islam or even the
training itself but I really do think
that people talk to people
professionally when they're actually at
the last end I think I disagree with
that a little bit because just taking my
friend as an example she she's been
married for four years she's she's happy
she's healthy she's got a child she's so
the family she's it knows I mean
but um ever since they had a baby it's
affected their relationship and she
would often come to me for advice and I
would help her and it would be
beneficial advice because I don't want
to break her home
so she obviously didn't want to go to
her in-laws nor to her family or to her
sisters so she decided I'm going to get
marriage coaching and she had a look on
Instagram because that's where we always
are these days
and she found
um a newly qualified therapist I think
she was or she must have had a few years
under a belt and she was charging three
grand for the entire session and my
friend was like shall I it's a holiday
yeah you'd think and I said look don't
do it so what she decided to do was read
the reviews and the reviews she noticed
someone was saying it's behind the
laughter my um therapy coaching my
husband now sits and has dinner with me
and she realized that actually
she had nowhere near as bad problems as
these other women did because it was all
coming down to her perspective
so if you want to make a minor problem
big all you've got to do is focus on it
and just feed it so I think that's
another thing
um I forgot my train of thought now I'm
so sorry no no that's okay maybe just
think about it sister
um for me personally I don't think going
to any form of you know psychology or
counseling background is a good idea I
think that's a really bad idea I think
if you and your husband cannot sort it
out between yourself there's no one else
that's going to help you
um I think you're now a married couple
you should be mature enough to deal with
that situation if you go to account
you already use it once I'm sorry
this is not something I don't even
thought it would do yeah
I just I just don't think it's a good
idea um there is no because I study
psychology for three years and then I've
done my masters in sociology and I don't
see any benefit in it in terms of you
know aiding each other in the marriage
because what that's going to do is it's
going to now reveal oh your husband has
trauma he has these childhood problems
you have these childhood problems you
need to learn to love yourself you need
to your husband needs to learn to love
himself so now you two need to separate
you need to find yourself you need to
find who you are this marriage now is is
got rid of your identity you don't know
who you are anymore so I feel like once
you go to these counselors
yeah there's skepticism
is there is there anyone in this world
who doesn't have some form of trauma
exactly true yeah but what these
psychologists are doing is they're
basically bringing up this trauma when
you it hasn't affected you that much but
now okay it's on the surface can I just
um okay Society did you remember your
point yeah
just wanted to say that if we go to seek
help there is nothing shameful or wrong
about that in fact I think we need to
seek help because there is only so much
that our brain knows and so much
experience that we have you can't just
sit there and think right I'm not going
to go to psychologist I'm not going to
get marriage counseling I'm not can't go
to my in-laws can't go to my parents
can't go to my friends so I guess I'm
gonna decide I'm going to get a divorce
and that's the end of your marriage we
have to try to get help but above all we
have to remember Our intention you have
to make intention that yellow please
help me understand this and process
process this in a way it's going to
benefit my marriage you're not going
there to ask the therapy as the
counselor right tell me my traumas I
want to know exactly what it is
therefore I can relive the pain and then
go away and focus on it they are merely
just trying to outline what could have
been the cause of this dispute that you
had so in the future you don't repeat it
and yes it involves that we go back to
what caused the trauma which emerges
pain but the pain has already been
caused you're just reliving it every
single day which is affecting your
marriage and your relationship with your
family friends and potentially you're
obviously setting an example to your
children as well so by revisiting trauma
that's not necessarily a bad thing I
think we we especially the Asian culture
we are told right don't talk about it
especially with men you can't cry you
can't talk about it man up be a man and
that is why we have so many broken men
today and it's so sad to see that when
there was help all along all they needed
to do was maybe have that cry we was
maybe reach out to a psychologist or
therapist or maybe just get some form of
guidance we cannot delete that from the
equation that is part of the equation we
have a lot we have therapy and we have
ourselves to make our own decisions or
in-laws which they can open up the
in-laws which is a discussion at hand
but yeah hijab
said that I think that she I mean I
think she's making a valid point the
question of to what extent are
counselors marriage counselors or
counselors themselves effective
there's two questions there really if
you think about this what extent our
marriage counsel is effective in Saving
marriage marriages and another question
is to what extent our council is
effective in general what kind of
counselors are most effective these are
the kinds of questions I don't know the
answer the first one I'm gonna have to
look at some studies to see yeah to what
extent are marriage counselors effective
I think the question from the second one
there is good effect I think there's
evidence of that uh it's certainly like
a Psychotherapy has is benefits CBT has
its benefits all of that has its
benefits you can approach all of those
things
um as a Muslim with no problem however
you need to know the assumptions of
these things and as a Muslim with a
moral compass you also need to realize
that I'm saying something now for
example in the counseling session which
I myself deem to be for example morally
okay morally Aboriginal morally Halal or
Haram even though this person in front
of me my acquiesce or reassure me that
what I'm doing is okay which is why I
think the best kind of counseling is a
synthesis between someone who knows as
you said Gabriel is like someone who
knows some something of the Islamic
Sciences something of Islamic
spirituality and at the same time from
our perspective these methods and
approaches and stuff like that so which
is hard to find it's hard to find but I
think that's there's a need for that
there's a need for for now Muslims to
produce their own methodologies which
which touch upon both cycle and
spiritual Realms of the equation or
something very interesting yeah I think
experimental psychologist has taken over
now more and more and I do believe that
you can connect a lot of the procedures
and processes to the son of Brussels and
because we have them like for example
just the basically right the process him
said that this Dean is is counseling
advice
when you
put that in the context and you look and
see that process the sahaba were not shy
to go to the process of cell that's how
much we learned from the Hadith process
with regards to you have difficult
marriage the effect of divorce you have
the effect of so many right and if you
look at the Hadith it'll be a sahabi or
sahab you know or going to the process
um having some form of interaction is
advising them but based on what right
what's the advice based on it's based on
the revelation of Allah
in something this is a difference and go
back to Allah I want to add to that
there are things that I was because I
was looking into this kind of like
informally myself the tensions between
um the Islamic system or Islamic hadees
Islamic you know Vision if you like in
terms of psychological preparation
before I call it that or counting well
you want to call it and psychological
methods and there are a few things I
want to kind of outline here but before
I do so
um I think it's important to realize
actually let me mention those first so
for example one of the things that the
process does a lot and has done
throughout the Sera which you'd never
find the council to do okay nowadays and
I say this tentatively or very rarely
seldomly would you find the counselor
doing a counselor with non-religious
affiliation
is tell somebody not only that they're
wrong but they have to persevere through
the uh whatever it is trauma the
so-called trauma they're going through
right so for example there's a very
famous Hadith the companions come to the
problem yeah this is they were being
um not just boycotting but they were
being tortured okay and then the prophet
the way he responded to that would be
completely against that against all
counseling uh instructions
this I think this is
and he said that basically the prophet
sallam said that people before you yeah
the Skins were their skins were taken by
the you know the M shipper basically
Combs of of things so in other words
don't complain right well don't complain
now the question is will the council
ever tell you stop complaining never now
this is the point that because
of that don't lose their license there's
another thing which is there's a there's
a Hadith yeah
which is uh also no it's
Muslim very famous Hadith
[Music]
the strong believer is better and more
beloved to Allah than the weak believer
and both of them is good but then the
processant continues he gives us now
advice of how to be a strong movement
how to be a strong person how to be
resilient so he gives number one
yes be cautious about that which is
going to benefit you through yeah
and seek refuge in Allah number two and
number three
this is very important do not quit when
you are afflicted with trauma wow do not
quit so can you imagine now nowadays
we're weakened as a society because we
don't have people telling us not to quit
yes we don't have the mental fortitude
and resilience that we once had because
we don't have someone like because
sometimes don't quit you see so a
counselor today will tell you yes you're
you're within your right to feel this
pain and this and that and this is the
trauma and all the content and they
won't tell you do not quit do this don't
complain stop complaining it's because
of your fault wow so now let me tell you
this is there's a shift here that I've
seen because I was looking at Carl Jung
who was one of the founding fathers of
cycle analysis itself actually there was
three major funding fathers and Carl
Jung was one of them
and I was seeing the the clients that he
had in the early days I was those videos
were online even
and um and she was uh there was a
particular woman that I was watching she
was saying that when he when Carl Jung
was doing the therapy session with her
she would get anxious stand up and get
angry and smash the door behind her and
she was telling her this is online right
and then the interviewer said did you
come back he said she said hey I came
back Carl Young even though he was a
psychoanalyst he had a more
interrogative style he put it on he
stuck it on her he said it was your
fault yeah it's kind of like that so it
was kind of like what you would expect
in an interrogation exactly because if
you want to get into the crevices of
your own psyche and you want to explore
what's your your problem is then
self-accountability is at the core of
that modern counseling does that
eliminates this kind of exactly and it's
a problem
we're gonna wrap up soon just two things
I want to touch up on you is not you
said yeah and when I sometimes I'm here
I'll do the show Etc and um even the
show that we did about new men one
career West bus space kind of stuff yeah
we talked about this uh the comments I
thought about four thousand comments
yeah um Etc and the thing is no anytime
I mention a certain some whatever it may
be and I see the same for my sister's
side when they say something pertaining
to Men I'm genuinely icy as they want
the best for us exactly when I say this
and I'm just talking like to those that
are watching when I say it mentions and
stuff we are men yeah we know what we
want so when we're seeing certain things
understand where we're coming from we're
not trying to have a go at you we're not
trying to belittle you we're not trying
to undermine you but if we're seeing
certain stuff which are bitter truth and
let's be real here yeah take it and
understand maybe he's trying to help me
better myself like you said now going to
Surah this is what I find this very
interesting because I don't think we've
touched up on this yeah yes we're gonna
in Charlotte in about five minutes we're
going to finish each other yeah okay so
um Allah says so when they the divorce
women have almost reached their term
then either routine with them uh with
fairness or part with them In fairness
and make two just men among from you
witness of either of the decision I know
and all Witnesses keep you test them
testimony upright for the sake of Allah
that is what anyone who believes in
Allah the last day exhorted to do now
here is very interesting yeah whoever
fears Allah he brings forth a way out
for him and provides for him from places
he would never imagine yeah now this is
one thing I think that we're really
really missing yeah and the cellophones
say this I would say anytime we would
commit to sin we would see it in our
riding Beast we will see it in our wives
when we would come home and be like okay
no one's out I didn't do nothing
they would connect it back to the Cindy
committee how many of us did they go and
say hold on a second
I don't praise Salah I'll commit major
sins I'm involved in the river brother
how much and you're telling me and
you're coming and telling me Oh man I
don't know why my marriage and I'm not
saying issues we've had prophets who
married Evil Woman
we knew righteous women who married evil
people
thrown the point is this how many of us
we talk about this culture that coach
this okay or when I'm good because Allah
says in the Quran if you don't know
something about somebody that knows we
understand but how many of us have ever
self-reflected and said you know what
hold on a second what is it that I'm
doing which one of my sins is it that
I'm doing that is causing the
destruction of my marriage right in
front of my eyes how many of us do this
and say you know what hold on a second
but I am I'm a guy who goes and speaks
to different girls left right center
every day yeah okay how come what kind
of Buttercup do you want in your
marriage or I'm a sister who goes and
talks either of my husband ever to
everyone and anyone that no one has
respect for an argument's sake yeah the
point is this if we are indulging these
sins if we're doing these evil actions
how do experience but the prophet saws
what he earns is Haram what he wears is
Haram and it's something along those
lines
how do you accept that Dua to be
accepted how did you look you're doing
all of these things and then you're like
and this is the biggest problem you know
what it is taking the uncle over the
knuckle what is it oh I know what like
you said sister yeah let's go on
Instagram we've got Instagram that's not
problem psychologist they can help me
taking the uncle over the knuckle what
Allah has prescribed is the best thing
for us of course there are Professionals
in their fields that we can go to
understandable but the point is the
following self-reflect my sins that I'm
committing understanding all of this I
mean all this stuff okay you know what
I'm saying from sins
Ramadan I do what's obligatory from
there things are not working okay let's
go to a counselor but what do we do when
I forget well why how many people come
down and say nobody they're like let's
go to a counselor sorry I wanted to be
around it's just really well like it
hurts me to see Believers divorcing well
like it's on a 50 rate one of the
reasons I started to show wallahi I
don't want to see that I don't want to
see that because the first thing shaytan
when sin was sent down to Hamilton did
they say they say you just say have to
drink alcohol to Rob to murder for what
[Music]
I'm about to stop right yeah
I would extract two solutions from this
discussion number one would be that
imams have to learn more pragmatic ways
of dealing with issues and that
if anyone goes into coaching it needs to
have an Islamic background like they
have to you cannot separate the two as
you're saying the separation this moral
relativism this division between what
Allah has revealed and what we think as
you said
I would say that would be number one
that we need to fix the problem by
actually targeting the the root cause of
this and that is ignorance lack of
submission
um as you said lack of
self-accountability
we don't we don't apply these houses
like hold yourself accountable first of
all the people and this is the main
issue right that'll be number one
um
number two I would say that um
you know divorce is climbing we need to
look at why are people divorcing not
just okay where do we go if they're
about to divorce
are people getting several companies
so so let's let's try to tackle there
that's nice
yeah I'm just another thing is that
divorce is not as bad as many people
think it is true I mean in the sense
that I think we have this perception
that okay well this is a very uh strange
time in history I was looking at some
particular I think it was uh I might be
one book it could be use of rapper
Rappaport his name is a particular guy
medievalist and stuff like that and he
came across a study in medieval Egypt in
the 8th Century or 9th century actually
they would send it to me yeah okay very
interesting and uh and it was it was I
think the biggest of this kind and on
women actually it was on 400 women in
villages in Egypt
and basically uh one third of them were
divorced
now which is very interesting because
well this is 800 years ago yeah
so don't forget like you know we look at
the companions I mean most most of them
I don't know if most of them that's
difficult to say but a lot of them would
have a big chunk of that their word was
so they divorced
that's the question oh yeah
one divorce happened to them in their
life happens yeah I get you I understand
that I think it's a very good point yeah
but what I was going to say was that the
point is is because if we make it all
doom and gloom it's kind of like there's
no bouncing back from it this is not a
strange time in history this is
something which people have recovered
from people have been able to get over
and do something afterwards
a very interesting Hadith not sure if
you guys have heard of it I'm not
married too so she was married to four
of us
she was married to Abacus
um
very famous Hadith where she was um
speaking and she was asked who's your
like your best husband that you married
and she goes from among the shoe like
the Elder generation
and from the young guys it was just not
sure
yes yeah so he wasn't yeah yeah but uh
so so Ali was like there's nothing left
for me you know so in a sense no but it
shows you this idea you asked this
question by the way who I don't know who
asked the question he said that yeah
there's nothing left for me today men
they would do something else for us
what I'm saying was that what I'm saying
was that there was more of an issue
there was more laissez fan yes well I'm
saying it was more like it's not a
problem like it's okay this is a woman
that she's been looking married to this
one and that one issue like exactly it
was very divorced woman today that's a
different topic
the reason why I'm bringing that to the
table because I thought like it's
important to realize okay divorces can
be the end but it can also be the
beginning yeah and so we have to have
like a different idea on that okay all
right let's just because we need to be a
marketing sister fahima and then
I think a lot of us need to learn our
Dean more than anything because as uh
sister Arthur mentioned before it's more
about the culture that's been performed
today and I think that's the main issue
luckily for me I was married to Iraqi so
and I come from Afghani in our heritage
but when there's certain communities
unfortunately as I see even as my
clients that regardless of what they
live by the rule of their culture and I
really think that that needs to be
addressed and that's the real problem
Another Blessing
um so brother said that therapy tells
you it does not tell you to actually
stop complaining when in fact it
actually does in a way it almost teaches
you how to stop complaining by making
you aware of your behaviors and your
moods Etc
for someone who is divorced and who's
had multiple therapy
um sessions with different therapists I
can definitely say that I have become
more aware of myself and my relationship
with Allah than I was prior to going to
therapy and maybe yes a lot well Allah
gave me that Ruth because that's how he
wanted to guide me
but we can't knock it down and say that
they don't teach you to stop complaining
because they really do I used to call me
about everything every single thing
there's traffic well to traffic did I
realized I was actually the traffic but
existential therapy yeah I think
psychologist
it's good to me to make that point we'll
just clarify something it's important I
think the point of stop complaining is
important because yes it's true that
there's that psychologists or counselors
would say things like you know you you
have trade neuroticism or something like
this is how to reduce it or whatever it
is or they give you uh ways what I was
going was further than that the Islamic
conception would tell you you're wrong
it's not just that stop complaining like
for example there's a in the Quran says
that
um
whatever happens whatever happens in
your life that it's your fault that's
what you're hands on yeah what your
hands have put forward and it pardons a
lot of sins yeah and it doesn't go what
we're saying is our model of therapy our
therapeutic method it's more brutal it's
way more brutal because it's saying that
in essence everything goes back to your
own behavior everything is
self-accountability and that level of
self accountability I'm saying yeah
you're right about the complaining but
it's not it's not afforded in modern
Yeah so basically understand there is
but not to the level of um
about you you said I was attractive can
you just yeah it's just a small little
concept of you know we're constant
complaining we'll see it's like they say
if you've got two wolves which on girls
it's the one you feed
so you go back to what you said yeah
you're right Islam tells you how it how
it is and
we have become overly sensitive
Unfortunately today we can't take
criticism even over the smallest thing
so we do need to be told how it is but
then we are not mentally or emotionally
or psychologically unfortunately
equipped enough to understand it and
actually process it change it and adapt
it into our everyday life therefore
that method unfortunately does not
always work for all of us and sometimes
things have to be sugar coated as sad as
it is maybe that is the approach that
this person understands and that is the
approach most of us understand these
days but it doesn't matter how anyone
says anything to you if you want to gain
something from it you will regardless of
how it said to you if you want to
criticize and reject it it doesn't
matter if your mom said it he does it or
you know the king said it you will
reject it so it comes down we'll come in
one more time
just one more thing because you're
making good points but I just before I
forget it because sometimes I've got a
train of thought and I forget it if I
pray I'm going to forget which is that
um the idea of sugarcoating something
okay the Islamic Creed cannot be sugar
coated in the sense that for example
we believe that okay there's such a
thing as depression the second one it's
a clinical disorder for example yeah and
it's it's differentiated but what's
referred to as transitory sadness and
usually diagnosis say like for example
transitory is having six months and
everything of six months is depression
for example right now there is a kind of
depression which is Haram which is
actually important for example you might
be surprised to hear this but well I
lost fantastic
whoever is hopeless from the mercy of
God is at uh is who will do that except
for disbeliever you know so the point is
on the spectrum of depression on the far
left side you have hopelessness in fact
if you're for example are studying
bipolar disorder hopelessness is in the
depressive episode would be the epitome
of depressive uh mood swings for example
what I'm saying is for example there are
some things which you cannot do as a
Muslim and that Islam has to set your
Criterion now you cannot sugarcoat those
bits for example the hopelessness uh
despairing from the mercy of God or for
instance uh like in this case being told
that you you everything essentially that
you're doing that's wrong is because of
your own sins now that might be very
hard for somebody who is a true a victim
of XYZ uh assault yeah but actually this
is because of a sin that you've done
yeah or it's because of a test that you
are beginning it's a very very difficult
thing to hear but that spiritual
Dimension yes once again is not
something we just believe in but we must
Implement and there's no sugar coat in
that aspect of it true okay we need to
pray a sister
um I just my my personal advice would be
that if you and your husband are in
constant arguments to come up before the
marriage you know your early days come
up with a coping mechanism so what are
we going to do when we both get heated
so I know I don't know if it's a Hadith
or not but obviously one becomes
um fire one becomes water you know try
and Implement that early in your
marriage try to implement mechanism for
example if you're both angry sit down
um I was watching this one guy like I
don't know if it was a TED Talk and he
was saying that when he argues with his
wife they both lay on the floor and then
the argument becomes minor because they
start to laugh they literally sit on the
floor together and they and they realize
how can you be angry with someone when
you're in that position so you have you
and your husband are a team I don't
think getting too many interventions
involved I think that will separate you
more and that will I don't think that's
healthy yeah I think try to come up with
methods yourself in the early days and
Implement them so they become a habit
you know as you grow yeah mostly I think
we might Ahmed about the when my wife is
right if I'm sick and yeah and yeah
talking about the philosophy these days
um the things about something about one
ends up on the floor
yeah literally yeah
because we've talked a lot about the
different approaches in Psychology Dr
Malik Padre has a book called The
Dilemma of the Muslim psychologist where
he addresses the Freudian method and
what how the Muslim psychologists have
built upon that premise or upon that
foundation and what the problems are
with that because you mentioned a lot
about foreign psychology and
experimental psychology is coming up is
crying right now as well as it's called
the The Dilemma of the Muslim
psychologist Dr malibadian I think it's
a Sudani scholar who is a psychologist
psychiatrist here in the UK mashallah a
great book I would recommend it
the most productive episodes we had I'll
be honest with a couple
um may Allah bless you guys well I I
believe these discussions are going to
help people out there who's on the verge
of divorce in law problems and we hope
inshallah that this somehow gives you
guys some kind of a guidance whatever it
may be a little from the Quran and our
few opinions here and there and may
Allah bless our honorable sisters who
have come here who've had their essays
well inshallah really means Allah to
hear our sister's side because we don't
know how you guys think so may Allah
bless you guys inshallah until next time
from the bitter trip show
if you want to be a part of the panel uh
go to the email here at the bottom
inshallah or if you have a question
you're going through something whatever
it may be married to or something or
whatever if it's something that we can
answer we would please email us
inshallah until next time from bitter
trip shop assalamu alaikum
awesome
the prophet salallahu said whoever
builds a Mischief for the sake of Allah
Allah will build for him a similar house
in Jannah on that day where Allah tells
us that our books will be given and
every little atom weight of God will be
there and imagine you see a mountain and
you're like what a lucky person which
righteous person
Allah says this is for you for me yes
what did I do
you allow people to pray you built a
Masjid I never had the money to build a
master to Allah you helped you gave
towards it and Allah gives you the
reward of as if you've built it donate
it now guys and do not delay and share
the video for extra Rewards
foreign
[Music]